we all know that food is essential to
human life and lucky for us the earth is
brimming with it in all shapes and forms
but have you ever wondered how people
who don't live on earth prepare their
meals well they don't have much
preparation to do compared to us keep
watching to learn about the contents of
space food and how astronauts can
prepare a full meal for four people in
about five minutes if you love food and
the amazing science behind making it
efficient for space make sure to give
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe for more today we're
showing you what astronauts eat mercury
program did you know that when humans
were first starting to step on the edges
of the Earth's atmosphere scientists
weren't even sure if it was possible to
eat food in space they worried about the
mechanism of ingestion and they even
worried that the body wouldn't be able
to absorb nutrients in zero-gravity John
Glenn the first American to eat in space
agreed with his fellow mercury team that
the food was not very good however he
was able to prove consumption and
nutrient absorption in space where
indeed possible his first meal consisted
of applesauce which he ate from a tube
and xylose sugar pills dissolved in
water
Glenn demonstrated that his body's
ability to swallow and digest still
worked in the conditions of
weightlessness the first foods brought
aboard the mercury mission for human
consumption were less than appetizing
they were based on army survival rations
and often consisted of a mashed up puree
of food packaged in an aluminum tube to
be consumed by sucking it out with a
straw the method of delivery to the
human body for consumption was efficient
given that it was direct with no risk of
loose to contaminate ship machinery this
is an example of pureed beef and
vegetables not exactly the most
appetizing given its similarities to
baby food many of the first astronauts
to eat the first space foods complained
especially regarding the lack of variety
urging NASA scientists to expand their
menus Gemini program by the time of the
Gemini mission space food science had
advanced a bit the most efficient method
to transport food to space was to remove
its moisture 99% of it to be precise
which we know as freeze drying or
dehydrating they also came in bite-size
ready-to-eat cubes these foods were
coated with gelatin or oil to prevent
crumbling which posed
issue back in the day and even in modern
times food crumbs and life-sustaining
equipment is never a good thing
aboard Gemini astronauts had packages of
combination meals like this one here
which consisted of an appetizer
vegetables and even dessert a serious
upgrade from the puree style food of
mercury to freeze dry a food item to
prepare for packing on board a ship
workers needed to rapidly freeze the
item in question before removing its
moisture via heating in a vacuum chamber
after this they vacuum seal the item
allowing it to be preserved for long
stretches of time even at room
temperature some items available
included from cocktail and butterscotch
pudding this is an example of a typical
Gemini meal consisting of strawberry
cereal cubes peaches a beef sandwich and
beef and gravy alongside the food are
the tools necessary for making them
edible the water gun which was used to
inject cold water into the freeze-dried
packages to rehydrate them and some
scissors to open the package and begin
the feast Apollo program the Apollo
mission paved the way for a better food
program this mission was the first to
incorporate the use of hot water in food
rehydration facilitating the process and
even improving the taste of the foods
taste improvement was significant
because weightlessness led to congestion
for the astronauts which meant a dulling
of their senses of smell and taste the
astronauts of Apollo 8 were treated to a
Christmas surprise when opening their
meal packages they found a thermo
stabilized meal consisting of turkey
with gravy and cranberry sauce but
didn't even need rehydration it could
simply be opened and eaten with a spoon
it was during the apollo food program
that astronauts were introduced to the
notorious spoonball a food container
whose contents could be eaten with a
spoon like this one for the astronauts
of the Apollo 13 mission their
spacesuits were equipped with a canteen
so they could drink liquids such as
water or juice as they worked on the
moon by the time of Apollo 15 solid food
snacks such as an apricot food bar were
accessible to keep the hungry astronauts
going as they labored across the surface
of the Moon for longer work periods the
Apollo program was long and arduous and
it required advancements in food science
for the astronauts who would eventually
become the first humans to step foot on
any celestial body Skylab Skylab was a
different program by NASA
and other extraterrestrial missions it
was the first and only Space Station
from the United States orbiting the
planet for six years before plummeting
back to Terra Firma Skylab was the first
u.s. space program to feature a unique
area for dining they were able to attach
themselves around a table and eat like
in a normal dinner setting in addition
quality of food greatly improved in
Skylab this was the first mission in
which scientists decided food edibility
was more important than anything else
and thus the menu got a boost in variety
and flavor there were 72 items on this
luxurious menu and the astronauts even
had a refrigerator and freezer for the
first time this meant that astronauts
were able to finally indulge in the
earthly delicacy of ice cream a favorite
among Skylab scientists additionally
because Skylab solar wings provided
power instead of fuel cells that
produced water the familiar dehydrated
foods of the past needed to be limited
to conserve on water instead foods were
preserved in aluminum cans like this one
or plastic pouches which could be
reheated and enjoyed because of the
advancements in food quality and variety
and the designation of a dining area the
crew members of Skylab were able to
choose their own meals prior to cooking
a luxury not afforded by previous
missions apollo-soyuz test project the
apollo-soyuz test project was a
politically loaded spaceflight between
the superpowers of the US and the Soviet
Union it was a joint effort that ended
the space race and more importantly it
meant that American astronauts were able
to try what the Soviets were eating on
their Soyuz missions this is an example
of a Soviet delicacy eaten in space
canned jelly beef tongue is surely a
unique and different experience for the
Americans at least it was a variety from
their standard menu which they certainly
grew bored of very quickly this here is
an example of Riga bread or Russian
black bread this mission was important
in showing that the Americans and the
Soviets were capable of working together
to reach their goals of scientific
advancement
they showed unity and camaraderie and
food played an important role in that
the food they shared broke down the
boundaries that their nations built here
you can see a photo of two American
astronauts Thomas P Stafford and Donald
deke slayton sharing tubes of Russian
borscht which is the beet soup in a
nature of fun they pasted labels of
Russian vodka for the two
as if to celebrate a drink in honor of
their Soviet space brothers the mission
was short less than two weeks but the
impact it had on the world due to the
tensions between the two great nations
was felt for decades after the space
shuttle the space shuttle only just
recently retired from his 30 year stint
of ferry and humans supplies and
machines to and from Earth even from its
first launch in 1981 however the Mills
eaten by the crew members were most
indistinguishable from meals consumed by
people on earth
the astronauts missions usually lasted
on average 7 days and they had the
choice between sticking to a basic menu
designed around the seven day mission or
choosing their own menus and meal
substitutions if they were to choose
their own meals a dietician would check
their menu to verify they would be
receiving the right balance of nutrients
this is an example of a typical meal on
its tray aboard the space shuttle not to
foreign-looking compared to the mystical
food tubes and cubes of earlier
spaceflight missions their meals were
prepared in a gallery that included a
water dispenser and even an oven
suddenly living in space doesn't sound
so bad
by the launch of the space shuttle
Discovery astronauts were living the
life famous chef Emeril Lagasse really
put the BAM in their meals constructing
the menu that included mashed potatoes
jambalaya and bread pudding
additionally the space shuttles were
loaded with fresh foods from a typical
grocery store about 12 hours before
flight which would be the first foods
consumed by the crew nothing beats fresh
fruits bread and vegetables after a
history of pureed dinners from an
aluminum tube the space shuttle missions
were the bridge between historic and
modern food methods for astronauts today
storage today there are six categories
into which space food falls today aboard
the International Space Station
otherwise known as the ISS the first
three categories are more familiar to us
earthlings astronauts can eat fresh
foods such as fruits and vegetables
natural form foods such as nuts
tortillas and cookies and dried foods
also known as intermediate moisture
foods such as dried fruits or even beef
the other three categories require
special preparation that doesn't
normally happen for food on our grocery
store shelves on earth freeze-dried
foods still make an appearance today
thermo stabilized foods as well are very
practical to take on board
they are heat processed to destroy
harmful microbes that might flourish at
room temperature so these foods can be
stored without the need for a
refrigerator or freezer
lastly ISS astronauts can also eat
irradiated foods these foods are placed
in foil packages and blasted with gamma
radiation or electron beams to inhibit
bacterial growth
this might sound dangerous but the World
Health Organization confirms these foods
are safe to eat most of these foods have
been prepared so they can be stored at
ambient temperature for long periods of
time
however some foods like fresh fruits and
vegetables have a limited shelf life and
are considered a luxury they are
delivered periodically with supplies
from ground crew to the inhabitants of
the ISS today's menu today's astronauts
typically cycle through a seven day menu
consisting of three meals a day and some
additional snacks their foods are
extremely familiar to us on earth
consisting of items such as scrambled
eggs chicken and rice beef stroganoff
with noodles
butter cookies tea and coffee beef
patties spaghetti and soup because
today's astronauts are usually aboard
the International Space Station which
welcomes scientists from several
countries with space programs the
astronauts are able to eat a wider
variety of food from different cultures
many foods come in ready-to-eat form
meaning that the crew of four can sit
down and have a dinner together in about
five minutes some foods however do need
to be reconstituted and heated a process
that can take up to 30 minutes perhaps
most importantly astronauts can make
special requests food can be comforting
and sometimes a little taste of home is
what they need to keep powering through
their research the food needs to be
checked beforehand to ensure that they
can be preserved in the environment of
the ISS and provide the right amount of
nutrients Canadian astronaut Chris
Hadfield requested maple syrup cookies
doc reata's and candied wild smoked
salmon allowing him to show his culture
to his crewmates
and to enjoy a taste of home French
astronaut thomas pesquet
even got to celebrate his birthday with
his home country's delicacy of macaroons
astronauts have a wider selection than
ever before shipping food to space the
International Space Station is usually
restocked with food and other supplies
every 90 days so an emergency food
system isn't exactly necessary that
doesn't mean however that a situation in
which food needs to be rationed can
to rise it has already happened once in
the past in 2004 there was a delay in
the next few shipment causing the ISS
crew consisting of Leroy Keough and
Sally Shawn sharp off to cut their
caloric intake by ten percent
they each lost between five and ten
pounds due to this today the usual
shipment process is quite streamlined
there is about a month of planning prior
to lunch and in the last two to three
days before the launch the food is
loaded onto the designated shuttle when
the u.s. space shuttle program was still
operational and responsible for shipping
up food and supplies it usually carried
3.8 pounds of food per astronaut per day
in addition it kept in emergency food
supply a board for anyone taking the
shuttle to join the ISS crew or return
to Earth that consisted of 22 days worth
of food per astronaut roughly 2,000
calories a day for each crew member
today's current shuttle systems include
two private companies hired by NASA
known as orbital ATK and SpaceX as well
as a disposable Russian craft known as
progress progress is designed to
resupply the ISS dock automatically and
then be filled to the brim with waste
and other garbage before being sent to
burn up in the atmosphere the
International Space Station astronauts
aboard the ISS have to abide by certain
nutritional requirements set by
dieticians they are told how many
calories they need to eat and how many
grams of protein fats and carbohydrates
collectively known as macromolecules
they need as well this process is not
too unfamiliar to those who are fitness
gurus counting calories and macros is
just all in a day's work the ISS crew
get to choose their meals and they even
get to have condiments to spice up their
foods if they don't suit their needs
such as ketchup mustard and mayonnaise
and even liquid salt and pepper because
the ISS houses people from different
countries the food varies but it also
means that crew members can share each
other's dishes and culture we've already
covered the sharing of us-soviet food
but did you know Japanese delicacies
such as Sudan noodles tempura soba and
curry noodles can be eaten aboard the
ISS as well Chinese crew members can eat
pickled cabbage and pork fried rice and
spiced beef by the time Christmas rolls
around crew members usually get to
celebrate twice the US and Russian space
programs tend to dominate operations
aboard the ISS
so they often have a typical American
Christmas dinner of turkey green beans
and cornbread on the 25th of December
then for the Russian Orthodox
celebration on the 7th of January they
get to indulge in delicious Russian
mashed potatoes meat and cranberry sauce
a beautiful way to bond and celebrate is
always through food and that covers all
the basis of what's really in space food
we hope to enjoy learning when
astronauts eat and if you did check out
10 foods you'll never buy again after
knowing how they are made thanks for
watching
[Music]